Скажи "гав"!
- Гав!
Саперна група починає свій робочий день.
У складі групи - кінологічний розрахунок.
Тобто кінолог Леонід і його напарник - бельгійська вівчарка Алмаз.
Спереду в нас рухається Алмаз, звісно.
Далі в нас сапери з міношукачами перевіряють дорожні лінії.
Це Київщина, Броварський район.
Російські війська підійшли до цієї місцевості впритул під час наступу на Київ, але не прорвали оборону.
Українські військові захищалися й залишили міни.
Завдання саперів - знешкодити їх.
Ми знаємо, що тут можливе встановлення підозрілого вибухонебезпечного предмета,
але наразі ми не можемо точно сказати, що тут є.
Нас попросили перевірити дану ділянку місцевості, попросили виявити, якщо такі є,
або підтвердити, якщо такого немає.
Першим іде Алмаз. Він за запахом відчуває вибухівку, навіть зариту в землю.
Коли сідає - показує, що знайшов.
Далі місце оглядає сапер - за правилами, він працює один, аби не наражати інших на небезпеку.
Виявлена міна ТМ-62М. Але без детонатора.
Тому ухвалено мною рішення подивитися під низ.
Під низом щось лежить. Що саме - визначити неможливо.
Він перевірив, виявив підозрілий предмет під міною.
Що це може означати? Це може означати, що під час підняття міни або під час її зрушування з місця вона може спрацювати.
Це попередження для тих, хто думає, що якщо побачив міну, то можна її відтягнути, підняти, щось викрутити -
вона може спрацювати.
З міною вже хтось провів маніпуляції, лежить вона в полі, тож найбезпечніше - знешкодити її на місці.
Так військові сапери працюють уже другий місяць, без вихідних.
Приїжджаємо, підготовка, більше п'яти годин не можна працювати саме з мінами, бо падає увага.
І зосередженість. Тому можеш щось пропустити.
Зазвичай у полі - це таке, більш-менш, проста робота.
Підійшов - здьорнув "кошку", якщо бахнуло, то бахнуло - ти за укриття.
Якщо працюєш в місті, в будинках, то там треба бути більш обережним, бо можуть що хочеш придумати.
Саморобні вибухові пристрої можна засунути і в пральну машинку, і в шафу, і в іграшку.
Поки побратими продовжують працювати, Алмаз отримує винагороду за роботу.
І це - зовсім не смаколик.
Оце предмет, за який він робить усю роботу.
Оце його улюблена іграшка, і він за цей предмет зробить пошук, який захочеш.
Знайде міну, знайде гранату, знайде вибухову речовину.
Алмаз - молодий пес, йому рік і сім місяців.
Він пройшов необхідне навчання, склав іспити, має сертифікат мінно-розшукової собаки.
І все ж щодня продовжує тренуватися.
Він шукає вже чотири основні запахи - це тротил, пластид, тен та гексоген.
Це всі елементи, які використовуються в мінах - у мінах протитанкових і протипіхотних.
Поле, дороги, узбіччя - стихія мінно-розшукової собаки.
Також Алмаз працював у квартирах у передмісті Києва, де росіяни залишали міни.
Утім, у ліси й посадки його не пускають, адже там можуть бути розтяжки.
Ось такий дріт і прив'язана до нього граната можуть стати смертельною пасткою і для собаки, і для людини.
Ця розтяжка на металевому дроті, тож на неї зреагував металошукач.
Але ліску не помітив би ані пристрій, ані Алмаз із його супернюхом.
Тож чотирилапого службовця бережуть.
Це мій напарник, і нам ще з ним дуже довго служити.
І дуже буде тяжко, якщо такий напарник загине. Дуже переживаю.
Кропітка робота з розтяжками й іншими вигадливими пристроями - це вміння сапера.
Денис Тригуб працював у Косові й на Донбасі, вісім років займається виключно саперною справою.
Каже: очі вже настільки натреновані, що помічають те, що звичайні люди можуть не бачити.
Розтяжку, встановлений датчик нажимної дії.
Це вже за зовнішніми ознаками - на ґрунті може відрізнятися колір трави - є трава така, а є пожухла, яка висохла,
бо вже хтось лопаткою обережно цей шар дерену зняв, поставив міну і закрив.
І вже видно на полі, що встановлено міну.
Пагорб, горбок якийсь, буває, настільки непрофесійно встановлюють міни,
що залишають чеки, залишають пакування.
Через півтора місяця після виходу з області окупантів Київщина все ще небезпечна, кажуть сапери.
Зараз здебільшого працюють із сільськогосподарськими угіддями.
А ліси, особливо на півночі, ще довго будуть забороненими для відвідування.
Північ Чернігівщини - тут досі помітні наслідки окупації.
Мирні села загарбники перетворювали на свої бойові позиції.
Рів, який тягнеться на кілька кілометрів.
Десятки укриттів для техніки. А ще окопи, бліндажі, їдальня і навіть ось така дерев'яна баня.
Це ціле містечко, яке російські війська облаштували в українському селі.
І звідси готували наступ на Чернігів.
Оборонні споруди окупанти викопали просто на городі Анни Петрівни.
Вона вже третій день вигрібає залізяччя.
Уже ж саджати треба, не знаю, що робити. І корів же ще не виганяли, бо сказали, там треба ще перевіряти.
Місцеві вже починають обробляти городи, але територію поруч ще обстежують піротехніки ДСНС.
Адже після росіян залишилося й чимало небезпечної техніки і боєприпасів.
На цій території знаходиться вибухонебезпечна техніка.
При її детонації була детонація бойового комплекту, який був усередині техніки.
Боєприпаси порозліталися навколо, і до того часу, поки їх не зберуть всі і ця територія не буде обстежена,
ця територія вважається небезпечною.
Ось, наприклад, "гордість" російської армії - самохідний зенітний ракетно-гарматний комплекс "Панцирь-С1".
За деякими оцінками, ця груда металу колись вартувала 20 мільйонів доларів.
Але нині це небезпечне місце - через ракети й артилерійські снаряди з боєкомплекту.
Якщо вона навіть вражає літак військовий, то розумієте, що там знаходиться дуже небезпечна вибухова речовина.
Тому рухати, переносити, грюкати заборонено взагалі.
Ці боєприпаси були зсунуті зі своїх стандартних місць, на них уже відбувся якийсь вплив,
і що там в них в механізмах, ми не можемо знати.
Серед поля - три згорілі танки.
Швидше за все - українські, які захопили й підірвали окупанти.
ДСНС-ники обережно, один за одним дістають зі згарища снаряди.
Будь-який неправильний рух може спричинити вибух.
Осколки на відкритій місцевості здатні розлетітися на 800 метрів.
Ось бачите, така штучка є? Ось. Він знаходиться в небезпечному стані. Виглядати воно має по-іншому.
Він уже деформований і невідомо, як там, де механізм знаходиться, в якому він положенні.
Ці хлопці-піротехніки працювали під обстрілами в Чернігові, витягали людей з-під завалів.
Тепер обстановка спокійніша, але робота - не менш небезпечна, але й більш кропітка.
Як показує практика, місяць бойових дій - це принаймні рік розмінування.
Ніхто не знає обсягів замінувань, по-перше.
По-друге, є досить велика кількість нерозірваних припасів, які не спрацювали з тієї чи іншої причини.
Зараз у нас на опрацюванні знаходиться більше 1400 заявок від населення по всій території області,
всі вони відпрацьовуються почергово, територіально.
Сусіднє село Бурівка ближче до білоруського кордону.
Так само пошрамоване згарищами техніки.
На виїзді з села військові з прикордонного загону показують "урожай", який з полів встигли зібрати місцеві.
Пролітає реактивна ракета, яка розкидає ці всі міни по околицях.
Вони призначені для того, щоб при доторканні до них або при спрацюванні вони розриваються
і в районі 50 метрів можуть знешкодити людей.
Тому вони небезпечні. Від вібрації спрацьовують.
Так як ви бачите - поля вже оброблені. Тобто люди на свій страх і ризик це роблять.
Касетні бомби, з яких по полях розлетілися ці міни, - заборонені міжнародним правом.
Попри це, за словами прикордонників, росіяни їх тут скидали десятками.
Українські військові першими обстежували місцеві села, поля, ліси.
Кажуть, окупанти залишали міни навіть у хатах.
Хоча мета таких снарядів - уражати військових, найчастіше жертвами стають цивільні.
Було багато ситуацій з холодильниками.
Це банально, але наші вороги залишають в холодильниках такі бонуси для людей.
І людина першим ділом, повертаючись, відкриває холодильник, а там уже сюрприз залишений.
Не з'їжджати з доріг на узбіччя, не гуляти в лісах, не рухати самостійно підозрілі предмети.
Ці правила ще довго будуть актуальними для регіонів, де відбувалися бойові дії.
За оцінками ДСНС, щоб розчистити всі території від мін і снарядів знадобиться від п'яти до десяти років.